la unión europea se prepara para cambiar
por completo su economía para marcar un
antes y un después en su política
climática hoy la comisión europea ha
propuesto un ambicioso paquete
legislativo de 12 leyes que permitirán
cambiar por completo muchos sectores por
ejemplo el automóvil a partir de 2035 se
prohibirá la fabricación de coches con
combustibles fósiles sólo se permitirán
los eléctricos también primera el
principio de 'quien contamina paga'
tendrán que pagar muchísimo más las
compañías aéreas por cada tonelada de
dióxido de carbono que emitan también
los cruceros los barcos y también como
otra novedad estarán las emisiones
contaminantes de los hogares que
provienen de las calefacciones para
hacer frente a la enorme factura que
esto puede suponer para muchas familias
y evitar la pobreza energética se creará
un fondo social de más de 70 mil
millones de euros para ayudar a las
personas a hacer frente a las facturas
también tendrán un papel clave en las
energías renovables al menos el 40 por
ciento de la energía que utilice la
unión europea tendrá que provenir de
estas fuentes
todas estas medidas tratan de poder
reducir al menos un 55 por ciento las
emisiones contaminantes de aquí a 2030
para que a partir de 2050 la unión
europea sea la primera región del mundo
climáticamente neutra